[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils se font un peu les opérations doudou
là leur message est sans équivoque les
immigrés illégaux nous sommes cernés par
les immigrés légaux
oui ces étrangers et masque lui il faut
qu'il fait leurs bagages
qu'ils quittent l'afrique du sud en a
peint c'est ça notre problème
il est limitant du mouvement inauguré ce
jour là une nouvelle branche dans la
capitale parlementaire du cap il accuse
les immigrés de prendre les emplois des
sud africains
écoutez ma génération s'est battu pour
donner naissance à une nouvelle
constitution on se dit que nous avons la
liberté d'expression notre droit de nous
exprimer s'ils se battre pour notre pays
à se battre pour notre économie et
xénophobe bien qu'il en soit ainsi
johannesbourg les militants d'opérations
doula sont connus pour leur descente
musclée dans les petits commerces
le quartier d'orange grove est
régulièrement ciblée et quand nous
sommes passés les commerçants venaient
tout juste de recevoir une lettre leur
demandant de licencier tous les immigrés
illégaux
ils nous ont juste donné la lettre et
son parti certains étaient agressifs un
peu plus loin un coiffeur congolais
installés dans le pays depuis 20 ans a
reçu la même missive
ces petits commerces sont pour les
sud-africains et seulement eux ne
voulons plus voir ces commerces opérer
plus longtemps car et les criminels pour
les noms sud africain d'avoir une
entreprise locale c'est illégal
vous voyez il n'y a rien même pas un
tampon de la police c'est le genre de
choses qu'on reçoit
mais où vont-ils faire leur photocopies
et faire leurs courses il ya plein de
magasins vides donc qu'ils peuvent louer
faire ce qu'on fait
la plupart des commerces fermés
momentanément leurs portes quand ils
reçoivent ces menaces les plus exposés
se cache comme didot un cordonnier
congolais qui vit en afrique du sud
depuis plus de 15 ans il avait été
défigurée lors des émeutes xénophobes de
2019 depuis ils rasent les murs il y à
un mois élite est à nouveau attaquée par
un groupe qui se réclamait de
l'opération du doubs la
wii ils sont venus pour me frapper et
chercher je ne sais quoi
mais moi je les ai vite se poser elle
parce qu'ils étaient bien plus nombreux
qu'au moins ils étaient une vingtaine ce
à sa date de 2019 et regardez là aussi
je n'ai plus d'oreilles j'ai passé deux
mois à l'hôpital de johannesbourg mais
je ne sais pas et à windhoek pourquoi
pourquoi le gouvernement leur laisse
t-il ce pouvoir to dig your sting ouais
beaucoup se demandent pourquoi les
autorités de pretoria laisse des actions
xénophobes se développer ainsi le
gouvernement répond qu'il prépare un
ensemble de lois pour mieux contrôler
l'immigration illégale qui attiserait
les tensions sociales il y aurait plus
de cinq millions d'immigrés dans le pays
dont seulement 3 millions de migrants
légaux
vous savez c'est très difficile de
contrôler les entrées aujourd'hui les
services publics travaillait sur un
prolongement de barrières ils n'ont même
pas eu le temps de finir de construire
ce kilomètres de barrières
supplémentaires que de l'autre côté la
barrière était détruite
avec le contrôle des frontières le
gouvernement prévoit aussi une loi
relative aux emplois une loi de quotas
qui limiterait l'embauchent des
étrangers par secteur une mesure qui va
dans le sens des sympathisants
d'opérations doudou là qui étaient
d'ailleurs présents aux consultations
publiques
opération l'a bien remarqué il ya des
compagnies qui emploie beaucoup
d'étrangers 50 pour son employé pour
certains et même 90 % pour
cet arsenal législatif sera déposé au
parlement avant la fin de l'année
en fait beaucoup de gens nous disent
qu'on aurait dû faire c'est ya longtemps
trôné en retard et qu'on doit accélérer
le processus
malgré ces tensions l'afrique du sud
reste un eldorado pour ses voisins à
robertson des affrontements entre sutout
et zimbabwéens faisait dix-sept blessés
en mars dernier des immigrés qui se
battaient entre eux pour travailler dans
les champs pour 10 euros par jour le
calme aujourd'hui revenu mais ces
réfugiés économiques assure n'avoir
nulle part où aller
franchement c'est difficile pour nous de
se dire qu'on va rentrer il n'y a rien
au zimbabwe ex il n'y a aucun emploi
rien qui nous permettent de prospérer
avec un taux de chômage proche de 35% la
situation sociale est tendue en afrique
du sud et les discours populistes des
sympathisants de l'opération doudou là
ne font que jeter de l'huile sur le fond
au mal et à l'eau ça tourne au c